>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Jennifer Harbster: So, good
morning and good afternoon.
This is always the
time where it's both.
I'm Jennifer Harbster.
I'm a reference and research
specialist here at the Library
of Congress with the Science,
Technology and Business Division.
I'd like to welcome you
guys to today's program,
Discovering the North-West Passage,
The Four-Year Arctic Odyssey
of the H.M.S. Investigator
and the McClure Expedition .
As I said before, we have a
lot in store for you today.
Author, Glen Stein, will be
talking about his recent book,
which I'd like to note has been
placed in the Royal Library
of Her Majesty, Queen
Elizabeth II at Windsor Castle.
We also have a special presentation
by Parks Canada Senior Underwater
Archaeologist, Ryan Harris,
who dove on the wreck
of the HMS Investigator.
We have extended the time
today for this program
to allow these two speakers, also
a question and answer period,
which will be after each speaker.
Glenn will start first and then
we'll have a question/answer period
that we need to limit to
about maybe 10 minutes or so,
and then Ryan will speak and
then we'll have a question
and answer period after that.
And then, following all of that,
we're going to have a book signing.
So to keep us on track,
I really need
to keep this introduction short,
but I want to let you know
about our speakers a little bit.
So it is definitely
my great pleasure
to introduce our speaker
today, Glenn Marty Stein,
who has been researching
and writing about maritime
and polar history since 1975.
He is a fellow of the geography
-- the Royal Geographical Society.
He's a life member of the
American Polar Society,
a member of the Orders and
Medals Research Society
and Lifesaving Awards
Research Society.
So in 2006, Stein began to do
in depth research for this book
and he published a two part article,
The Voyage of HMS Investigator 1850
to '54, which was awarded the Orders
and Medals Research Society
Journal prize in 2008, '09.
This is not Glenn's first visit
to the Library of Congress.
In February of 2013, Glenn was a
co-presenter for a program by --
a program called, By Endurance We
Conquer, Shackleton and Lessons
of Leadership from the Imperial
Trans-Arctic Centenary Expedition.
Glenn is also a formal
editorial cartoonist
for the newspaper La Prensa.
And the library recently acquired
some of his drawings to add
to our amazing cartoon
and caricature collection.
So anchors away and join
me in welcoming back,
Author and Historian, Glenn
Stein to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Glenn Stein: Well, thank
you very much, Jennifer.
I appreciate that introduction.
And also too, I want to make
a little announcement here
about the room we're
in because it --
it somewhat has a connection to
what I'm going to talk about.
We of course, are in the Mumford
Room and one of the investigators
on the expedition was
named James Nelson.
And in the Arctic, he
became quite friendly
with a gentleman named
William Mumford, who was on --
on one of the rescue ships
called H.M.S. Resolute.
So they actually stayed friends
after they came home
from the Arctic.
So there's a little bit
of serendipity there.
But thank you to the Library of
Congress and to everyone involved
with this production today.
I appreciate the welcome very much.
And of course, to Ryan Harris
for so graciously coming down
and presenting with me today.
And I also want to mention the
tremendous support I received
for many years now in
researching and producing the book
from my editor, Layla Milholen
and everyone at McFarland Books.
I also wanted to thank you for
being here today and also, my wife,
Marsha, for her kind support
all throughout these years.
And also have mentioned
that our twin daughters,
Aliyah and Rebecca
would be here today,
except their college studies
trumped even dad's book launch.
That's okay, that's okay, I --
I can appreciate that and --
and I respect them for that.
There's also a couple
anniversaries of sorts
that I would like to mention.
I have a slight connection
with exploration myself.
In fact, 26 years ago this month
when I was working at Cape Kennedy,
I used to work in security
out there.
I supported my first space mission
and it was the Galileo
Spacecraft that went to Jupiter.
So at that time, they
launched the spacecraft
and it took six years before
it reached the planet.
So there's a connection there
between the length of time
and the days of old
exploration and space travel.
There's also another
anniversary of sorts today,
it was 20 years ago this month
when fellow polar historian,
A.G.E. Jones wrote to me and put
it -- things in perspective here.
Jones and I have become
very friendly
and corresponded quite a bit.
And he wrote to me once that he
had seen Charles Lindberg land
in Croydon, England in 1927.
So, Jones had been at it a
little bit longer than I had
and in the last letter
of the line --
last line of the letter that he
wrote to me on this occasion,
he wrote, "Carry on wondering as
that is the way to get to the bottom
of a story that everybody
has taken for granted."
I've always remembered that.
Four years after this time, I was at
a convention in San Jose, California
and I had seen a woman
named Diana Birch,
who I had never personally met, but
we had corresponded over the years
and I went up and introduced myself.
Well, as my name left my lips she
shouted, "Oh, you're the polar man."
And this is the kind of response
I often receive from people.
In part, because I'm a
native Floridian, so --
so nobody ever puts that
together, they never quite expect
that when I tell them I --
I research polar history.
They -- they look at me rather
strangely and I have to explain it.
And then afterwards, I actually came
across a man named John Tamplin,
who is medal -- was a medal
collector and researcher himself,
who I again, had never
met face-to-face,
but we had corresponded
quite a bit over the years.
At this time, John was in his early
70's and I was 36 years of age.
And I when I introduced myself,
this huge grin swept across his face
and he took me by my
shoulders and shook me
and exclaimed how wonderful
it was to meet me.
And I found out later that John
was shocked at my youth for someone
who was interested in
polar exploration and --
and had the knowledge that
I had acquired at that time.
He just couldn't believe
that I was that young.
So this is -- the experiences
I've had on occasion from people
that I've run across over
the now almost 41 years
that I've been doing research.
What I'm going to do to start off
with is I'm going to read part
of the preface from my book,
Discovering the North-West
Passage .
It gives you something of a --
of a overview of what I had hoped
to achieve when I started
the book and of course,
what I did eventually
I hope achieve.
The story that follows is true.
This is a balanced account
of the human story behind the
Four-Year Arctic Odyssey of the men
of Her Majesty's ship
Investigator, during their search
for the missing Franklin Expedition
in the North-West Passage.
Through an unfiltered lens, I have
gone to great lengths to understand
and accurately depict
the events and the people
in which they were involved.
On April 11, 1970, I stood in
amazement on a Florida beach,
gazing upon Apollo 13 as
she hurdled to the moon.
Two days later, hundreds of human
and computerized minds melded
in a race to save three
explorers trapped
within the frigid void of space.
To the Victorian mind,
the Arctic was the moon.
Like outer space, the Polar
Regions offer life and death.
And the difference between
them hangs by a thread.
Exploration has always been
as much about, if not more,
the human species'
struggle with itself
as its struggle with
the natural world.
With the investigators, I focused
on seeking out possibilities
and then finding answers.
In the following pages
understanding emerges
through the careful
peeling away of layers
of reality these men
confronted during the expedition.
As I immersed myself in
the journals, documents,
and letters of the investigators and
other polar explorers of the period,
their words washed over me.
I delved into Naval customs,
ship construction, oceanography,
ice navigation and the effects
of extreme cold and starvation
on the human body, anything
that allowed me to inch closer
to their 19th Century world.
At the same time, I strived to
understand the indigenous peoples
with whom the sailors and
marines came into contact
and obtaining a sense of their
culture and in particular,
their relationship with Europeans.
What I'd like to do is give you an
overview of how this book evolved
and some of the highlights, some of
the things that I actually was able
to discover during my research and
very much focus on the word evolve
because the book did change
as I wrote it and grew.
And I was very, very pleased
with the result in that regard
because I was able, I think, to
bring out even a richer story
than I had intended to or foresaw.
And perhaps there's no better
way to begin than the end.
After the book was finished
and it went to press,
I remarked to my wife one night, "If
I never write another word again,
it will have been worth it."
And a word about writing, I
think is very appropriate here.
I often tell people that the -- the
thing that really should be kept
in mind is that I spend a lot more
time thinking about what I'm going
to write than actually writing.
So -- so that has really remained
uppermost in the whole process.
And this along with the
self editing that I did
through the whole process meant
that there was a tremendous
timesaving in the long run.
Another example is, I built my
bibliography as I went along,
so I had a quick reference
myself and I was able
to actually make corrections
in it at the end
because I had already built a full
bibliography instead of trying
to create one at that time.
From the beginning, I was very
concerned about getting it right
and preserving the memories
of the investigators,
that was extremely important to me.
I've been in contact with a lot
of descendents of the expedition
and I certainly did not
want to write things
that were not true
about these people.
And one of the things that I did was
I wrote a letter to the historian,
David McCullough and
expressed my concern.
And he was very gracious in writing
back that in part, "What a fine
and engaging letter from you.
Thank you very much for your good
spirits and understanding of what's
at stake in writing a book.
Gives me a great lift."
So from that, I thought, well, I'm
probably on the right track here.
I probably -- I'm probably
heading the right direction.
So, one of the things that
really impressed me in going
into this was -- or made an
impression on me I should say,
is how I needed to make the writing
and the experience for the reader
as authentic as possible.
And in a way, what I wanted
to do was use the investigators
words as much as possible.
And I found a lot of unpublished
material that was out there
and fortunately, I was
able to really go through
and juxtapose all the published
and unpublished material
and hopefully come up with
a really authentic idea
of what occurred in
many circumstances.
These are typical sailors
of the time period,
although there was nobody as young
as the boy you see right here.
Let's see here -- right
there, that's a boy,
small boy who was not uncommon
during Victorian days aboard ship.
They could be as young
as nine or ten years old.
But these other sailors really
represent very typical sailors
of the period.
Also, these are Royal Marines from
the same time period and again,
very, very typical of who you
would see except for again --
whoops, sorry about that,
the drummer boy right
here -- the drummer boy.
Now in order to do
what I set out to do
and really present an
authentic narrative,
I needed to create an infrastructure
and I knew this right
from the very beginning.
And by that, I assembled a whole
host of folders in my computer,
anything from the Franklin
search expeditions all the way
through to something
like specialized medical information
related to the Polar Regions.
So I set everything up
and I was able to easy --
easily juxtapose all this
information and move forward
in my writing and explain things,
hopefully in a very
clear way to the reader.
Also too, I knew illustrations were
going to be extremely important,
so I began gathering as many
illustration as I could related
to Arctic scenes, ships to
various people, anything I could
which I felt was going
to be important.
And I figured that the best
thing to do was to infuse these
in the text relative to
the subject matter at hand,
so the reader would see the subject
matter that I was writing about
or was being written
about and relate to it.
Also too, I wanted to bring
people as close as I could
to the investigators themselves and
this meant displaying and writing
about particular artifacts, the
very, very personal artifacts
like -- whoops, this one here, okay.
This is a naval general
service medal, which was given
to Private First Class,
George Parfitt.
He was one of the eight Royal
Marines who was board investigator
and the medal was given to
him only in the months prior
to leaving for the expedition.
Now, the Marines in particular
were required to wear these medals
on formal occasions and since
the ship was going to be away
for several years, every reason to
believe that medal was with Parfitt
through the entire voyage and went
through the North-West Passage.
I also set about to create
individual biographies
of all 66 men onboard.
And in this regard, a lot of
things came to the surface.
One of the things that came to
the surface is that over 39 --
sorry, 39 men over -- out
of the 66 who were onboard,
actually had served together in the
nine years prior to the expedition.
This meant that there was a certain
unity among the crew before the
expedition ever began and
that was very, very important
for the cohesiveness of the ship.
In assembling the biographies,
I also investigated the ships
that the men had served on
before and after the expedition.
I created physical profiles for
them and I even compared them
by the counties from
which they were born.
As you can see, many of the --
many of the men actually came
from the southern counties
of England here.
Now this only represents England and
Wales, there were people represented
from Ireland as well, and Scotland.
Two of the men actually
stood out in particular
because they were men of color.
They were of African descent.
One of them was born in England,
the other claimed to have been born
in British North America or
today as we know, Canada.
I looked into him much more closely
and I was able to actually come
up with a good bit of
circumstantial evidence,
very strong circumstantial evidence
that he wasn't Canadian at all,
he was a runaway American slave, or
at the very least, his parents were.
And again, there was a lot
of circumstantial evidence
that pointed to this fact.
So, I was very, very pleased with
-- with that because it's very hard
to actually come across
that sort of individual
and that sort of information.
Certainly a lot of men of color
served in the Royal Navy for --
for many years throughout the years,
but to find that sort of information
and connect it to a particular
individual and a particular place
and time is very difficult.
Now, the driving force behind the
ship was of course, the captain,
Robert John Le Mesurier McClure.
There were portions of his
character that can be explained
in different ways and -- let
me get to him, there we go.
And what is so important about
McClure is the more I looked
into his family records -- and there
were quite a few different family
records from different
people throughout the years,
the more contradictions
I ran across.
So, I really had to
-- to work those out,
I had to find out what
was true and what was not.
And some of these things were --
were innocent things, things to --
just mistakes of years, mistakes
of locations and things like that.
But it's very difficult with McClure
because his father died
before he was even born.
He died when he was
serving in Egypt,
in the early part of
the Napoleonic Wars.
So it -- it was very difficult to
come across some information in part
because of that, but also because
his mother was a wife, a mother
and a widow all within a year.
So she went through a
tremendous experience.
The baby McClure was actually
given up to his godfather to raise.
Now, this in and of
itself, was not unusual,
but what was really
interesting was the fact
that McClure was the only child
of that household for many,
many years before his godparents
had children of their own.
I think this had a big effect on him
because he wasn't the
golden child anymore.
And his godfather was a
former Army officer --
former general, and when McClure
rejected going into an Army career
and chose a naval career instead,
he was behind the curve
by several years.
So he actually joined the
Navy at a much later age
in his youth than normal.
So again, these things
had a cumulative effect
on McClure getting
ahead, making rank,
and progressing in a naval career.
I'll read briefly from my book
and it will give you an idea
about McClure's naval
environment and some of the things
that had a direct impact
on the expedition.
"The post-Napoleonic War
Navy was spit and polish.
And the naval officer prided himself
in the keen ship handling
throughout harnessing --
through harnessing the wind.
McClure was caught in the midst
of this transition from sail
to steam propulsion that
began in fits and starts
in the 1820's and 1830's.
But the steam engine was an
inefficient and unsightly thing.
Steam, whose grotesque
and clumsy engines,
whose monstrous smokestacks
there belched from --
belched forth the smuts,
the constant traded mess
from the combustion of filthy,
Newcastle coal and the smell --
first smell in contamination
of oil."
So, steam was seen as an ugly
thing, something to be [inaudible].
And that was the environment
that McClure knew.
It wasn't just McClure who
was affected, there were many,
many other people, including
one of his commanding officers,
who impressed this upon
McClure quite heavily.
His name was John Ross.
The way this played into the story
was McClure had a bitter conflict
from the very start with
his second in command,
Lieutenant William H. Haswell.
Again, from my book.
"While McClure's crewmen were
bounding through the renewal
of old acquaintances,
a grave fracture
in his command was taking place,
threatening the ship before
she ever left England.
And the problem started at the
top, during the tow down river,
Lieutenant Samuel Creswell's
pen painted an ugly scene
for his parents.
The captain continues
to be very civil to me,
but poor Haswell catches
it on every occasion.
Yesterday the captain went on
in a most foolish way with him,
saying he should not be in this
ship, that he was incompetent
to be first lieutenant, that he
would write to I don't know whom.
So why did McClure insist on
humiliating his first lieutenant,
a man who's support would
be crucial during the long
and difficult voyage ahead by
declaring Haswell should not be
in this ship and that
he was incompetent?
To some degree, the
answer as wrapped
up in Haswell's previous postings,
the Devastation and
Penelope steamships.
Haswell had served in several --
several sailing ships before this
and had been successfully promoted,
but he was now well on his way
to becoming Investigator's
persona non grata
because of the stern warnings John
Ross has repeatedly given McClure
against ever taking anyone with a
background in steam propulsion."
So this had a tremendous
effect on the structure
of the expedition again,
before it ever left England.
One of the things that I was very
concerned about in my writing was
to appeal to the broadest
possible audience.
And when I say that, I'm
talking about anybody
from the lay person all
the way to the scholar.
So bridging that gap as you were,
was going to be something
of a challenge.
And what it meant was I needed
to make the text very readable
and I also need to set the stage
in the first two chapters
for what lay ahead.
What lay ahead was a tremendous
amount of unpublished information
that was very detailed
and as time went on,
I realized there were certain things
that would never be understandable
within that framework, so I had
to create indexes or indices
in order to deal with them.
One of these indices, for instance,
was the primary sources indices
and this was so important because
there was a web of intrigue
and unanswered questions among
the journals that I had read
from the captain, from the
assistant surgeon Peers,
even from the carpenter Ford.
There were a lot of things
that weren't adding up,
a lot of missing parts,
literally missing parts.
Let me give you an example.
I was able to prove beyond a doubt
that McClure kept two journals.
So this is a multipart
journal and there was a copy.
And what happened is through
time as far as I know,
there's only one volume of
that journal in existence.
The question comes, is that the
copy or is that the original?
And this sort of thing
actually reverberated
through the other journals as well,
particularly the surgeon's
journal, Dr. Armstrong.
I also created an index
of notable sled journeys.
And the reason I did this is
because when you can
attach a particular person
to a particular place at a
particular time, you can track them
and you can associate those
people with specific events
or disassociate them
with other events.
So I created an entire index so you
can go back and you can see who was
where and when they were
participating in various events.
These sled journeys actually
created stories within themselves
because you see certain
people appear again and again.
In other words, they were
favorites among the officers.
This isn't unusual because there's
a certain connection that you get
with someone when you
spend days, weeks,
months on the sledding
trail with the same people.
You get to know them,
they get to know you,
you get to trust them,
they trust you.
And it also played into
the story very much
because Haswell being somebody who
was desperately hated by McClure,
was kept out of the
picture more and more.
So he doesn't show up a lot of times
in the writings or he's referred
to only slightly, sometimes
not even by name.
Several years ago, I began work on
a two-part article about this award,
the Arctic medal, 1818, 1855.
And I had intended to --
to publish it eventually,
but as I did the research for
the book, it became obvious
that this award is
actually an integral part
of the overall story, here's why.
The reverse of the
medal itself -- whoops.
The reverse of the -- of the
actual award here was designed
by Samuel Creswell.
And that was no mistake.
Creswell had been called to
an audience of Queen Victoria
and had done paintings
during the expedition
and she was very impressed
with them.
So he had an inn right there.
The other thing is that Her
Majesty, Queen Victoria herself,
since she was a princess, had a
great interest in exploration,
particularly polar exploration.
And she became convinced that
the shape of the medal needed
to be octagonal, not round like
war medals before and after it.
So it stood out.
She wanted something that
was going to stand out,
it was going to be
different and recognizable.
For that information, I'm very
grateful to the Royal Archives
at Windsor Castle because I was
able to get special permission
to actually access letters to
and from Queen Victoria
on this very subject.
Now, for all this rich detail
and explanations and there --
believe me, there's a lot more,
there's so much that's new
in regards to this expedition
that I have in my book.
I have to tell you, I'm actually
going through the book now
and making my own notes because I
-- I can't even keep up with it all,
so I want to have my own
notes on some of this
and where it actually
falls in the book and --
and that is an ongoing process.
But for all this detail and
all the richness of the story,
it's important to step back and
take a look at the big picture
and the big picture is this.
There is no one route through
the North-West Passage,
it's actually several routes.
McClure discovered two of them.
And through the years while these
guys were out there exploring,
the ice conditions made it
so that things could change
tremendously year to year.
In one year, an explorer may have a
lot of luck getting through the ice,
a lot of ways to go through the ice,
and another year, be
entirely blocked.
So you're really at
the mercy of nature.
That's very important to remember.
The other thing is, no
one man can actually claim
to have found the North-West
Passage.
McClure's experience has really
capped 30 years of experiences
of many other men who
had gone before him,
most of them British explorers, in
finding a way through the Arctic.
And during this time,
these men relied very,
very heavily on native peoples
for guides and assistance.
Perhaps most importantly in this
regard, McClure's experiences
and those of his fellow
investigators really can be used
as a yardstick and understanding
what happened to Sir John Franklin
and the men of the
missing Erebus and Terror.
And it is my earnest wish
that my writings will be
applied to that very end.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Harbster: So
now, we can do a question
and answer period before
we have Ryan Harris come
up from Parks Canada.
So, are there questions for Glenn?
>> Glenn Stein: Yes?
>> Jennifer Harbster: And
overly repeat the question
for the cameras so we know --
>> Glenn Stein: Repeat the question?
>> Jennifer Harbster: -- yeah.
>> Glenn Stein: Sure.
Yes?
>> Mr. Stein, I enjoyed
your book very much.
>> Glenn Stein: Thank you.
>> There -- the question I
have about Lieutenant Haswell,
what is your judgment
of Lieutenant Haswell?
Did he merit the condemnation and
criticism of his commanding officer?
>> Glenn Stein: Well, it was --
it was -- for what I could find,
it was very, very enlightening to
show that there was an incident
where one of the masts was
damaged in a storm, for example,
and Haswell was indifferent
about inspecting the damage.
And McClure was furious about
this and -- and literally wrote --
wrote him up to the Admiralty.
And McClure rode him very
hard, so at one point,
Haswell supposedly said
to him, "I've been told
by people much your superior that
I'm a very good naval officer."
So -- so it's hard to understand
whether Haswell was saying
that because he was being arrogant
or he was saying that because,
"Look I'm really tired of you
-- you riding my back, okay.
And I can do my job."
And I think when you consider the --
the situation and the confines of
a ship, that Haswell had a really,
really difficult time staying on
-- on even civil grounds with a man
who went out of his way
to humiliate and hate him.
I mean, McClure tried to
get the guy off the ship;
he tried to kick him
off the ship in Hawaii.
And he was basically told by -- by
other naval officers on the scene,
"You really don't want to
do this, you know, you --
you don't want to kick your
first lieutenant off the ship."
For one thing, there was
nobody to replace him.
The other thing too is Haswell
was actually the flag lieutenant
of the commanding officer in
his prior command, prior ship.
Now that meant that he was
basically a political officer,
he was the guy's right arm.
And I think very much Haswell had
some sort of political connections
that probably irritated McClure.
He probably didn't like that
because McClure was not someone
that had grown up with these
or gone through his service
with political connections.
He got them only very late.
So -- so it's a good
question as far as, you know,
was Haswell really deserving
of McClure condemnation
because it's really
a double edged sword
in those -- those circumstances.
One of the things by the
way, I would love to find,
anybody finds it I'll give
you a million dollars,
I kid you not, is Haswell's journal.
Haswell's journal was actually
retrieved from the investigator
after it had been abandoned, but
I've never been able to track it.
And I even went to the -- to the
lengths of going to the wills
of his descendants to try to see if
it was passed down in the family.
I could never find a trace of it.
I get the impression that he
never wanted it to be shown,
he never wanted it to get out
there, certainly never published,
so it's possible it was destroyed.
But as far as I can tell, it was
never passed down in the family.
But stranger things have
happened, so you never know.
Another question?
Anybody?
>> Jennifer Harbster: Onto the next.
>> Glenn Stein: Okay, oh
and then there -- thank you.
>> Jennifer Harbster:
All right, oh wow,
that did that without even -- magic.
So our next speaker is Ryan Harris.
He is a senior underwater
archeologist with Parks Canada.
Ryan received his bachelor's degree
in anthropology from the University
of Toronto and a master's
degree in maritime history
and nautical archaeology from
East Carolina University.
He has been working with Parks
Canada since 1999 and has taken part
in more than 50 underwater
archaeology projects.
His archaeology work has
helped to locate the wreck
of the H.M.S. Investigator
of which he then dove
onto conduct a survey of the vessel.
Just recently the Parks Canada
underwater archaeology team located
one of Franklin's vessels,
missing vessels, the H.M.S. Erebus.
So today, Ryan is going to
share with us some of his work
that he's done with the Investigator
and I think some updates
of the Erebus work too.
I should also note outside at the
book display, we have a book called,
Lost at Sea -- Lost in Sea .
>> Lost Beneath the Ice .
>> Jennifer Harbster:
Lost Beneath the Ice ,
which has actually documents
some of the work that he's done.
It's a beautiful, colorful book.
So please join me in welcoming
Ryan to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Ryan Harris: Good afternoon.
Thank you for the warm introduction.
More or less, I'm just going to
offer some eye candy here to --
to support the launch
of Glenn's book,
something I've been looking
forward to with anticipation myself.
And I think that's --
in the close of time,
I think this book might
stand as the --
the authoritative history of
H.M.S. Investigator, perhaps for --
for generations in the same way
that Richard Cyriax's seminal work
on the Franklin Expedition
remains the --
the authority since its
publication in 1939.
It is, I think in 2010 or
maybe 2011, where Glenn
and I first began to communicate.
We had just recently discovered
the wreck of H.M.S. Investigator
in Canada's high arctic and
so we had a mutual interest
in the -- one another's research.
And fairly early on, I was
able to come to a sense of --
or come to respect Glenn's
meticulous research nature,
his thoroughness and his
humility in which is quite a --
quite an attractive trait, which
is a pleasure to work with.
And yeah, I look forward
to getting back to Ottawa
and dissecting this work
which will be instrumental
in our ongoing research on the
wreck site of H.M.S. Investigator.
I'll provide a bit of
historical background just
to facilitate my talk, but it'll
include a lot of images of --
of these two rather
extraordinary wreck sites
which hope you'll take interest in.
Of course, in broad strokes,
the Franklin Expedition
departed Greenhithe County Kent
in England in May of 1845.
With a significant fanfare and --
and seemingly justified optimism
that finally this sublimely equipped
expedition would finally, you know,
find the elusive North-West Passage,
something that had been the --
the object of the English
mariners since Elizabethan times
and the times of Frobisher
and -- and Hudson later on.
And so the -- the two ships
Erebus and Terror with 129 men
that ultimately entered the
Arctic, including Franklin himself.
Obviously, things didn't work out so
well and all of these men perished
under certainly, rather
grim circumstances.
This of course, launched -- I'll
start with the Investigator,
but this launched what
is often described
as the largest rescue operation
that's ever been staged
in human history.
Countless expeditions were
launched by the Royal Navy,
privately thereafter,
American expeditions as well,
to try to locate these two missing
ships and -- and the missing men.
H.M.S. Investigator among its
-- amongst its claims to fame,
of course, that it was part of the
first Royal Navy expedition to --
to look for Franklin and his men.
In fact, it was three years in
that the Admiralty, I think started
to grow apprehensive as to the --
the wellbeing of the expedition
and gave Clark Ross,
who actually was offered
but declined the command.
And probably feeling a
certain tinge of guilt perhaps,
started to develop a rescue plan
and it's under Ross's recommendation
that the Investigator was
purchased into the Royal Navy.
It was actually building in
Greenock, Scotland we believe
as -- as a -- as a whaler.
And it was converted for
Arctic service and along
with H.M.S. Enterprise, made the
first search expedition in 1848,
heavily modified to
withstand Arctic conditions.
In fact, the -- also under the
supervision of William Rice,
a master shipwright
in the Royal Navy --
heavily reinforced with iron plating
in the bow and very thick deck beams
and all kinds of internal iron work.
And so in 1848, Enterprise and
Investigator, under the command
of James Clark Ross -- I think
he took it upon himself to try
to spearhead the -- the search.
They essentially followed in
the wake of Franklin essentially
where he was ordered to
proceed into Lancaster Sound.
And that's where they themselves
encountered impenetrable ice
and they were [inaudible]
winter, the northern end
of Somerset Island at Port Leopold.
By the time they did send a
sledge expedition down Peel Sound
and finding absolutely
no concrete trace
of the Franklin party having
ventured in that direction,
that may in fact have sealed the
fate of Franklin and his men.
The -- given that -- it
persuaded the -- the --
the Admiralty that Franklin did
not proceed in that direction
and it really refocused a lot
of their search efforts
farther west and -- and north.
That said, Franklin was certainly
up against a ticking clock
and it ultimately may have
not have made a difference.
So returning to [inaudible] 1849,
Investigator Enterprise were
hastily outfitted again,
reprovisioned for a return trip.
This time anticipating as we said,
that Franklin must have made it much
farther west, they were sound --
sent around South America and
through the Straits of Magellan,
stopping at the Sandwich Islands
where Hawaii is as Glenn mentioned.
Where the -- by this time, the
two ships had been separated
in a storm off of -- off of
South American and in 1850,
McClure led the Investigator alone
and plunged into the Western Arctic
and automated into fame and infamy.
So he made very steady progress
in 1850 following along the
North American mainland.
Again, with the explicit orders
to try to locate some trace
of -- of the Franklin party.
So in late 1850, they had
identified Prince of Wales Strait,
one of the -- one of the arteries
of the North-West Passage now.
And sending a sledge team by October
26, they had identified the --
in fact, this communicated
with this open body of water
that had been surveyed
by Sir William Edward
Perry many years before,
identifying indeed
as a navigable route.
Over wintering in the open pack,
the following navigation season,
Investigator proceeded
clockwise around Banks Island
and encountering treacherous
conditions such as this.
This is a -- one of Left-tenant
Creswell's iconic paintings
and ironically is almost always
used in the context of talking
about Franklin, not about
Investigator itself.
And I -- hopefully the --
this book and the discovery
of the wreck site will help to --
to properly restore the
significance of this work.
But as the navigation
season drew close to an end,
as dusk was descending
and with a driving snow,
the investigators were
following along the northern end
of Banks Island and inadvertently
blundered really into the confines
of -- of what is now
called Mercy Bay.
They -- stranded on a --
on a sandbar and spent much of
the next day lightening ship
and were able to get
it off and that's
where McClure made
the often criticized,
but somewhat logical decision not
to press their luck any further
and that they would
overwinter in Mercy Bay.
Ultimately, they spent two
increasingly harrowing winters
with their provisions
and rations being reduced
and their health failing.
And when things were looking
rather grim and McClure had to --
hatched a plan to send half of
the ship's company off to try
to secure rescue, which would
-- is generally admitted --
have amounted to a death
sentence for all of these men.
And would simply have delayed the --
the demise of everyone
else left onboard the ship.
When a solitary figure appeared over
the horizon coming across the Strait
that now bears McClure name, and
Left-tenant Pim from H.M.S. Resolute
which just happened to
be across the Strait.
And this ultimately is what spared
the investigators the same fate
that Franklin had by
then experienced,
just the serendipitous
rescue that came
from another Royal
Navy ship in the area.
So, of course, we start -- we
had already started on the --
the more -- more recent search
for the Franklin wrecks,
Erebus and Terror, when we
took a parallel interest
in H.M.S. Investigator.
This shows Banks Island
that we had mentioned
and our interest was supported
by the fact, in Parks Canada
that we happened to
have a national park
that borders Mercy
Bay here on all sides.
This Aulavik National Park or second
northern most park in the country,
which gave us something of a --
of a pretense to go and
search for the ship.
Given that much of the ship's
stores, spars, ship's boats,
significant number of
provisions were landing on shore
as an emergency depot by the
crew and a subsequent party,
after the ship was abandoned
in 1853, and after the rescue.
Beyond that, we had a certain
amount of useful information to go
on archeologically as to where we
might find this ship and this coming
to us by the hands of Frederick
Cravay [assumed spelling],
who was the master of
H.M.S Intrepid in company
with -- with the Resolute.
And he was sent by the
Resolute's captain, Captain Kellett
to conduct a condition
assessment of Investigator,
a year after it had been abandoned.
And his sledge team arrived
and encountered Investigator
looking much like this
with significant amount of
water, solid ice actually
in the forward hold washing over
the freshwater holding tanks,
down by the head and
listing to starboard.
And that convinced them that
the ship would soon flounder.
So he, and his men, and the
sledge team took the opportunity
to batten the hatches, but only
after removing what remained
of the ship's stores
that were firmly frozen
in the ice in the hold.
And they were added to the --
the depot of stores on the
western side of Mercy Bay.
So in 2010, our team, the underwater
archaeology team working closely
with our Western Arctic field unit,
undertook a fairly ambitious search
for this ship in hopes that
it might be found close
to where it was left
at anchor by the crew.
That said there were competing
possibilities, different hypothesis
as to what may have befell the
Investigator after it was abandoned.
The Inuvialuit, which to say the --
the indigenous people
of the Western Arctic,
their reports to the Canadian
Arctic Expedition in 1915 suggested
that in fact the ship had either
been broken apart on shore
or that it had drifted
out into the open --
open Strait and had
sank in deep water,
which for us would
not be very good news.
But we went to Mercy Bay anyway.
And so in July, this is what -- what
the site appeared like after all
of the ice had cleared from
the harbor, sort of the --
from the -- from the bay.
And in fact as we flew over it
for the first time it was
completely stogged with -- with ice.
That's what my Newfoundland
wife would say.
And so after a year of preparation,
we thought that we might
not stand any chance to look
for it at all -- after all.
But we spent some time setting up
a base camp on the western shore,
slinging load after load by
helicopter from a nearby airstrip,
the ominously named Polar Bear
Cabin and the northern part
of Aulavik National Park.
And while we readied our
Marine survey equipment
and inflated our zodiac boats,
a [inaudible] archaeology team
undertook a detailed study
of the depot or cache site
as it's generally known.
This is Henry Carrie from our
Western Arctic field unit,
an archeologist looking at
the most prominent feature
that survived onshore from the
Investigator Expedition prior
to the discovery of
the wreck site that is.
And that's what -- that's what
remains of the seven tons of coal
that was landed on shore, as well as
a large scattering of barrel staves,
hundreds and hundreds from the
provisions that were put there.
This is something that really speaks
not just to the nautical nature
of -- of the cache, but
the fact that the -- the --
the Inuvialuit made repeated
visits to Mercy Bay to make use
of these materials for
upwards of 60 years it is said.
And this is actually a frame from
one of the investigator's boats,
from one of the ribs so to speak
of the boat, and we can tell
that it's a lapstraker, a
clinker built boat given the --
the edges of this frame.
But every piece you'd find is
broken into links no longer than --
than let's say a foot and
that's so they could harvest
and extract every single copper
and iron fastener from all
of these boats to assist,
you know, their --
survival really, which
affected their material culture.
There are many, many interesting
historical, archaeological
and anthropological parallels that
can be drawn between Investigator
and Franklin's ships and this
is one of them in a small way.
Right on top of the cache site faced
down was this bit of boat timber,
this is actually the stem
of one of the bow timber
from -- from one of the boats.
And as you turn it over, you can
actually see that it's engraved,
there's a W that stands for the
Woolwich Dockyard, where the --
the ship outfitted in 1850.
A Royal Navy broad arrow mark --
this is government property mark
which you'll see repeatedly in this
presentation, as well as the length
of this particular
boat, likely 22 feet.
This immediately reminded
us of a find made
by the McClintock Expedition, 1859.
All kinds of McClintock
Expedition maps
and books on display here today.
And by his subordinate
Left-tenant Hobson
on King William Island found the
remains of one of the ship's boats
from Erebus or Terror with
three skeletons in -- inside.
And ultimately, the boat's stem was
recovered by the Schwatka Expedition
in 1879 and now is on -- visible
at the National Maritime
Museum in Greenwich, London.
Here we see again, the W
for Woolwich, the date April
of 1845, length of the boat.
And this was actually
built by contract,
it didn't have a broad arrow
mark, so this a carvel built boat,
which was often provided to the
Navy -- sorry, a clinker bit --
built boat that was provided
to the Navy under contract
because the doctors
were doing this anymore.
Also the analysis of the cache
included a systematic magnetometer
or walking gradiometer survey,
which identified all the magnetic
anomalies from the cache --
hoops from the -- the [inaudible],
small nails, whatever the --
the Inuvialuit didn't
-- didn't detect.
But also these three anomalies here
and at east of western [inaudible]
of Western Ontario suspected these
might in fact represent the graves
of the three investigator
crewmen who were not rescued.
We know their names, John
Boyle, John Ames and John Kerr,
who also come to scurvy just before
the -- the Resolute rescued them.
And actually John Moore,
my colleague in the unit --
oddly enough, he was
eating a lot more --
more oranges, not wanting to suffer
the curse of Johns in Mercy Bay.
And ultimately, if you go exact to
that point on the magnetometer map,
well, you see them,
these outlines of --
of three graves where the permafrost
has not slumped because it's held
up by a coffin, these are
coffin shaped outlines,
which makes us think of the three
Beechey Island graves that were
from the H.M.S. Erebus
and the Terror.
So as the [inaudible] team did
their work, we took to our --
our 19 foot zodiac and conducted a
towed side scan sonar survey to try
to locate the wreck site.
And in contrast to what you'll see
with the search for Erebus later
in this presentation, this
actually went very, very quickly.
And after a year of
preparation and the effort
of getting all this equipment to --
to the Arctic, ultimately
it took us three minutes
to locate this wreck site.
I wish it was always that -- that
easy and it certainly is not.
But this is one of the
earlier images, the showing --
showing the Investigator wreck site,
this being the stern and the bow.
We could tell right away that it
was in remarkably sound condition,
still preserved to, really to the
height of -- of the weather deck,
the upper deck, although
impacted by the ice.
And you see ice scouring all
about the perimeter of the site.
And this is a little sketch by --
by John, showing the ice conditions
and we weren't really even
intending to survey that day,
we were just testing the
equipment because the --
the bay was still solidly
full of ice.
We just had this small serpentine
route that we could follow
to test the equipment and that just
happened to be exactly where --
where the wreck was located
and generally very close
to where Frederick Cravay pinpointed
it for us kindly enough in 1854.
So it was a follow -- it was
another year before we can return
to the wreck site of the
Investigator to dive it,
a very long year for us in the unit
to waiting within anticipation.
And the -- just an
extraordinary experience
of diving a pristine
shipwreck site this far north,
at 74 degrees northern latitude.
And only when you see it
up -- up close can you --
can you really appreciate
just the magnitude of it,
but really just how
well preserved it is.
This is a close up looking at
the stern and the entire hull
of the ship is clad with
copper because the ship went
around South America through
the Tropics, stopping at Hawaii,
it was clad in copper to deter ship
boring teredo navalis, a shipworm
and gribble and that sort of
thing, which would eat the wood.
And we could still see the copper
and draft marks, which here shows
that we're 12 feet above -- above
the keel and the [inaudible] upon
which the rudder would have --
the hinges essentially that
the rudder would have swung on.
So we had a very productive time,
we made over 100 dives on the site
or nine intense day of diving,
often diving until 4 o'clock
in the morning because
at this time of --
of the summer, we enjoyed
perpetual daylight.
And here we're inserting
a high definition point
of view inspection camera into the
nooks and crannies below the decks,
trying to identify what
spaces would preserve their
archeological integrity.
Ultimately what we found is that
the entire ship was silted --
silted in, which was disappointing
in a way, but actually bodes very,
very well for the preservation of --
of materials down in the lower deck.
And here we see the 20 odd
cabins for the ship's officers
and including the great cabin for --
for McClure in the stern with
Haswell and Creswell and Armstrong
and -- and everyone else.
And we think that many of these
spaces will actually survive intact
representing small time capsules,
representing the shipboard life
of those specific individuals
which is very exciting
for us as archaeologists.
And then deeper down into
the bows of the ship,
beyond what we can glimpse,
certainly there's just enormous
potential, the botanical
and biological samples
that are preserved,
probably with their labels even
intact down in the bread room,
whatever would perhaps remain in
the spirits locker down below.
But other structures like Mr.
Sylvester's patent heating
apparatus, a coal fired heater
for warming the ship
in Arctic conditions.
And we had enough time
to have a good look
and to recover a certain
number of representative
and diagnostic artifacts, not
sure you can see it in this light,
but the entire site is
covered by a thin lens of silt.
Here you see the outline of a --
of a boot, which upon recovery you
can see is a typical square toed
Arctic sea service boot
very, very much like finds
that have been contributed
to the Erebus and the Terror.
This Arctic boot from Starvation
Cove where the final survivors
at that time succumbed we believe.
And really demonstrating
just the very close parallels
and material culture
that we stand to identify
between the two shipwreck sites.
Probably the most [inaudible] fact
that was recovered from Investigator
in 2011, and you can just see
it as it was lying in situ,
there's the trigger
and over here the --
the butt plate for this very
well preserved 1839 pattern,
procession-sidewall musket.
Which we carefully wrapped up and
were able to recover to the surface
and now it's in conservation
treatment at our labs in Ottawa.
And again, we can find close
parallels to this sort of firearm
in the relic collection at
the National Maritime Museum.
From all these implements
from the Erebus and Terror
that were recovered by the
Inuit and ultimately purchased
by various search parties
in the mid-19th Century.
In fact, the -- the brass tang
plate on this particular firearm is
so well preserved, it
preserves a lot number or a --
or perhaps even a serial number.
The date likely of assembly in 1842
and a WXD, which during this period
of time, actually stands
for the Woolwich Division
of the Royal Marines.
So we can actually attribute this
particular firearm to the handful
of Royal Marines that
were garrisoned to --
to Investigator for this
second Arctic voyage.
So in broad strokes, of course,
we can see the progress of --
of the investigators
where they overwintered,
ultimately where the ship
was abandoned in 1853.
And they made their way
across the North-West Passage,
ultimately largely on foot.
As the Resolute and the Intrepid
were ordered to be abandoned
when they got trapped
on the ice by --
by Commander Belcher off of
Cape Covern [assumed spelling],
but eventually they all piled onto
a small number of transport vessels,
including the H.M.S. North Star
and made their way back home again.
So discovering the
North-West Passage,
but also affecting the first
European, let's say, transit.
Although largely on
foot and in the process,
really the first circumnavigation
of all of north
and South America at the same time.
Here of course, is the
reconstructive route taken
by the Franklin party just to
change gears, which obviously ends
in a dead end here off of
-- of King William Island.
Where the two ships, Erebus and
Terror, are last seen by whalers
in Baffin Bay, where they first
overwintered in 1845 to 1846 off
of Beechey Island, where
those three graves from --
from that party are located.
And the following navigation
season 1846,
we believe they descended Peel
Sound, were beset in ice or trapped
in ice, the grip of which would
not release these two ships
for the following two years.
So we know from this rather
iconic [inaudible] note that's now
on display at the National Maritime
Museum in Greenwich, which tells us
until the discovery really of the
Erebus wreck site of really the most
of what we -- we know at
least from European sources.
So in this note, this is kind of
a terse form letter that announced
that things were going
reasonably well.
In 1847, where they overwintered ,
was signed by Left-tenant Gram Gore
of -- of the Erebus, but they
return to this note a year later
and left a far more chilling
account in the marginalia.
This signed now by a -- by
Captain Crozier of H.M.S. Terror
who now had assumed the --
the command of the overall
expedition announces
in typically terse
Royal Navy style that --
that Franklin had died
the previous year
and they don't bother
to say why or how.
And announced their intention
to desert the two ships
five leagues northwest --
north north west of this point,
giving us sort of a last report
of position of where
the ships were last seen
by their European cruise,
supposedly.
And that's really where
the historical record ends
when it comes to Erebus and Terror.
So what we had to rely
on archaeologically
in the search was a
corpus of Inuit's testimony
from mid-19th Century that
was recorded by a succession
of search parties and including
McClintock we mentioned, in 1859,
10 years later, Charles Francis
Hall, an American publisher
who felt he was on a mission
from God to -- to save these men.
Ten years late -- sorry,
10 years after McClintock
and certainly 20 years too late.
And Frederick Schwatka, a U.S.
Army cavalry officer who was --
in around 1879 who
probably maintained no hope
of actually finding survivors,
but the hope that they
might find some --
some telling, written record.
So, all of this evidence is
kind of [inaudible] captured
in this UK Admiralty chart --
chart 5101, which in red shows
observations of skeletal remains,
the -- the sun bleached bones of the
Franklin crew as -- as they are --
now are strewed across
the landscape.
But in blue, and this is
all color coded and --
and mentioned in the legend,
which I've dropped off here
for display purposes, but the
blue is the Inuit accounts
and actually specifically
says in the --
in legend that they're not
inherently trustworthy given
the source.
Ironically, with benefit of
hindsight, we now see that in fact,
it was Inuit testimony
that was instrumental in --
in our ability to locate the wreck
of H.M.S. Erebus just the
last September in 2014.
Let this shows two possible
trajectories for on one of the ships
that end up in the -- the southern
Queen [inaudible] Gulf area.
The Inuit's suggest that
the fate of the two ships
after they're abandoned
somehow parted ways.
That one of the ships
somehow made it farther south,
the other ship sunk earlier
on in deeper water, they claim
and that they weren't able
harvest any materials from it.
So we've been looking for both -- in
both areas since 2008 and by 2014,
we had amassed over 1200 square --
actually, 1400 square kilometers
of side scan sonar coverage, an
area significantly larger even
in the area of Los
Angeles, substantial area.
Typically using this tool as the
mainstay of our toolbox in searching
for shipwreck targets, this is
a toad side scan sonar system,
which produces acoustic two
dimensional images of the sea floor,
identifying superpose objects
including hopefully shipwrecks.
So, over the course of six years,
towing a side scan sonar system all
over the place and staring at
the monotonous flow of the data
down the sonar screen,
something called a waterfall.
We had not encountered
a single solitary trace
of anything cultural,
not a log, nothing.
It is a very barren
landscape, at least to our eyes
and there was just
nothing, no promising leads.
Finally in 2014, we
actually caught a break
and actually our trustworthy
archaeology counterparts have been
working with us side
by side since 2008 --
came across this object
during their effort to set
up a GPS reference station
with our hydrographic service
on a nearby island.
And the helicopter pilot, Andrew
Sterling, came across this object,
which was brought back to the ship
and pretty quickly
we were actually able
to identify what specifically
it -- it represented.
And I don't think you can
see it in this lighting,
but there are two broad arrow marks
of these ubiquitous
government property marks
that clearly told us this object
came from one of Franklin's ships.
There are only so many Royal Navy
ships sunk in the area after all.
And in consultation with the ship's
plans of Erebus and Terror, in fact,
it is only a couple
of hours before John,
he was able to decipher
what exactly this was.
And that was a lower pintle,
the anchor point for one
of the ship's davits for deploying
and recovering the ship's boats
over the quarter -- the
string quarters of the ship.
So this also told us that a large,
heavy iron object likely indicated
that a wreck was close at hand.
Something that the Inuit
[inaudible] who had cached
that behind a large boulder would
not want to carry with them all
across the Arctic, being rather
heavy and not terribly useful.
So it appears that they broke off
the pintle end and probably fastened
that into something useful, and
then dumped it where it was found.
So excitedly the next day
we took to the water again
and shifted our survey area
a little bit to the east.
And with our survey vessel,
the [inaudible] research
vessel investigator,
where H.M.S. Investigator was
unsuccessful in locating any sign
of the ship's investigator, the --
the second got lucky
on September 2, 2014.
And under absolutely
sublime surveying conditions,
at long last we found
the first images
and it was absolutely unmistakable
when it first appeared
on the screen.
This is actually a few passes later
after we approached it differently,
but just the cathartic,
you know, release --
relief really, that after six years
of searching with growing comments
from the -- the media that,
why were we wasting our time,
suggestions that even if we found
something, it would be nothing
but toothpicks on the bottom.
Why were you bothering?
Finally, this remarkably intact
Royal Navy shipwreck appeared
on our screen.
At this time, we didn't
know which ship it was,
that would take quite
a bit of research
as subsequent investigation.
But from the initial sonar
images, we're able to tell
that it was intact again, to the
-- the height of the weather deck,
that it was standing given the
acoustic shadow, a full four
and a half or five meters
proud of the seafloor.
And we could actually see telltale
signs of the Royal Navy modification
for Arctic service, so we --
we were absolutely convinced that
was the ship we were looking for,
as if there's much doubt.
So excitedly after the announcements
made by our prime minister,
in Ottawa we were all
sent back to the site
and our entire dive team deployed
and excitedly made the first dives
on the wreck of -- of the --
well, we now know it to be Erebus.
But I would certainly describe
as the most remarkable sensation
of my professional career.
There's no doubt about that.
As everywhere, your eyes were dark,
there's something remarkable
just lying there,
tucked in amongst the
collapsed timbers.
And it was one of the first
things you could see are these two
beautiful brass six
pounder canon just lying
on the seafloor right
stern of -- of the wreck.
And this is something I find
interesting is someone who's
interested in -- in steam propulsion
in the Royal Navy in
the mid-19th Century.
This is the outer stern post
and the inner stern post
to get excessively tactical,
but you'll see these cast bronze
railings, these are tracks
that actually allowed the ship's
two bladed propeller to be lowered
into position and then
retracted again.
The Erebus and the Terror were
the first ships to be outfitted
with a steam driven screw propeller
for the purposes of
polar navigation.
And so, we're very interested
in studying this as --
this time Marines -- the Marine's
steam power was still very much
at its infancy.
And here you can actually see the
-- the tracks and the little slot,
this is where the propeller shaft
would've -- would've rotated.
And we have, of course, the
reference from the ship's plans,
the National Maritime Museum,
and this shows this rather crude
looking two bladed propeller,
they didn't even have
the terminology set yet.
They called it the -- the fan blades
of the -- of the -- of the screw.
And this does detail what both
the tracks, but the mechanism
that they would -- they would --
when retracted, they would
lower these chalks wooden
and access the tank,
to stop up the plate --
the space because they wouldn't
want the ice to get a purchase
on where the propeller was
and -- and rip the stern off.
And we actually have referenced
this interesting sketch
by Left-tenant Irving
from the expedition,
actually during their dispatches
sent home from Greenland.
And in a letter to his sister,
Katie, he, you know, shows a sketch
and this is one of the
-- the steam engines.
And worth mentioning, of course,
these were not purpose-built
Marine steam engines,
they were adapted locomotive
engines from the Greenwich Railway.
Basically dropped into the aft hold,
turned sideways and with the --
the wheels removed to
drop the propeller shaft,
so really, really interesting.
Something that is interesting about
both ships again, is that they're --
they represent these
rather unique repositories
of a very obscure Victorian
industrial technology.
These are the ships
main bilge pumps,
these are patented Massey double
action lift and force bilge pumps.
Something you can't find anywhere
else in the world, you can't even go
to the science museum and --
and see what these look like
and how they operate, really
we only have recourse done
through the -- our archaeology here.
There is a close up of
the -- these are the --
the pump heads to be turned
with a big bell crank to --
to siphon the water
out of the ship's hold.
They wanted to outfit
these ships with the --
the most capable technology
available given the difficulty
of the task that was hand to them.
So this is a plan of
the upper deck of --
of the Erebus, trying
to build pumps there.
And these illuminators
or deck prisms
that would filter ambient
light below decks
to make the place a bit more
hospitable during the long
winter months.
And this is actually kind
of hard to see I got to say,
but here I'm actually looking
through a deck combing,
so right on top of
the -- the upper deck.
This is a skylight that would've
been situated directly over top
of the -- the ward room, so I can
imagine the sailors casually walking
by here and eavesdropping
conversations just below here
between the senior
officers, where probably a lot
of significant decisions were
-- were -- were mulled over.
And this is the -- something
we don't commonly see on --
on shipwrecks, certainly in Canada.
This is the ship's tiller, but
it's actually solid bronze,
usually be something
made out of wood.
And there's the end of its
12 feet long and this is
where we would notch
into the rudder.
Essentially this is a big
beam that allowed the --
the rudder to articulate.
It's bronze, we think,
because the --
the ship's hull was lengthened to
accommodate the propeller, so now --
all of a sudden the rudder's now
at several feet farther raft,
so they need a really strong
rudder, this is maneuvered
by the ship's helm, the
tiller -- or the wheel.
So they -- like many features of
these ships, they are heavily,
heavily overbuilt to
withstand Arctic conditions.
The -- certainly the
most iconic artifacts
that we encountered right away,
on actually the very first dive,
this is the ship's bell, the
only artifact we recovered
in the first series
of dives in September.
And again, it's emblazed into the
-- or embossed actually with the --
the Royal Navy broad arrow.
And very conveniently, the
date 1845 that would --
archaeology should always
be that straightforward.
So quickly, we wanted to get back to
the site, we only had two days to --
to reconnoiter the site before the
-- the season ended in September,
so we went back with our Department
of National Defense in April.
As you could see, it's solid
ice in this point in time.
And the Department of National
Defense set up an ice camp
for about 50 people right
over top of the wreck site.
And by boring these large holes,
we're able to dive through the ice
and access the wreck under
very, very stable conditions.
One of these blocks would take about
five hours to painstakingly melt
with -- with a special tool and
then to lift clear of the surface.
And so working closer with our
fleet diving units of Halifax
and elsewhere in Pacific Region, we
conducted 80 dives over the course
of five days and got to know the
wreck site a little bit better.
I should mention this is
called Operation Inuvialuit,
who was supported by
the United States in --
in one respect, that
the camp was demobilized
by two ski equipped C130 Hercules
from the New York International
Guard.
And so, these poor guys built
a runway on the ice for weeks,
just plowing snow for weeks on end.
And finally, they were able to land
these gigantic Hercules planes to --
to load all the camp in, which
made things much easier at the end.
So after the April dives, we
started preparing again for a return
to the site this last
August and September,
a year after the wreck discovery.
And enjoying some of the best
weather conditions we have ever seen
working in the Arctic.
Our team made in excess of 150
dives, clearing the overgrowth
of kelp, which concealed a
lot of the ship's structures.
And here you can see just
the remarkable water clarity
that they were enjoying at the time.
This is like diving the Caribbean
in terms of how far you can see.
So this is a view of the
port side of the Erebus
with the exposed upper
deck beams where the --
the deck planking has peeled away.
And looking up at the
bow and you can get a --
get a sense of how close
is just the surface,
the wreck being only 11 meters deep,
the top being six meters below
the -- below the surface.
And along the port side, this again,
after all the kelp has been removed,
you -- you really get a sense of
how well preserved the ship is,
the ice channels on either
side of the hull, typical of --
of Royal Navy ships
of Arctic exploration.
And subtle details we can
finally see with the kelp removed,
including the draft marks.
Here you see this copper
cutout roman numerals,
showing 20 feet this
height above the keel.
And what's neat is that they're
half obscured by this iron plating.
Like Investigator, Erebus
and Terror were both fitted
with a five-sixteenths layer of
-- of plating of the bow to --
to help protect the bows
from -- from ice damage.
But it's really the -- the artifacts
that tell an evocative story.
Only after they were cleaned
in the lab, could you make much
out of these two buttons
recovered from the lower deck,
from actually inside
the ship and it --
it is hard to see unless
you're holding it in your hand,
but both show a fouled anchor
over the crown over top of it,
symbol of the Royal Navy.
And the lettering which took us a
while to make out, Royal Marines.
So both these buttons would
apparently derive from one of the --
the jackets or tunics
from one of the --
could be any from either ship,
so one of the 13 Royal Marines
that entered the Arctic.
And also really delicate
artifacts which tell us something
about life onboard the ship
would only scratch the surface,
but this is a patented
medicine bottle
and it's embossed the name Samuel
Oxley and the other side, London.
And Mr. Oxley was a royal chemist
who at this time had
patented concentrated essence
of Jamaican ginger, which apparently
could cure just about anything,
including arthritis and seasickness,
which makes sense given the ginger.
But also is a cure for
hypochondria ironically enough.
And then the artifacts
just lying in plain view,
here you see from [inaudible]
ceramic plates.
Over here is a -- either a pewter
or even perhaps a silver
plate, serving platter.
And this is the circular
deck illuminator,
one in which has fallen
down into the ship.
After cleaning some
of the -- the poor --
some of the ceramics
is really quite vivid.
And actually it preserves the -- the
stamps on the back and even the --
the type, which is a Whampoa
pattern, which a lot of --
of officers serving
in the -- in the --
in the orient of would
return back to England
with their own personal collections.
And this is where -- make reference
to when the ship was last seen,
really before -- before we
stumbled upon it in 2014.
And the Inuit's specifically
mention going onboard this ship,
that they saw four sets
of footsteps trialing off
to Adelaide Peninsula nearby,
perhaps the final survivors.
That finally after the ship was
deserted, we think it would seem
for a second time [inaudible]
that they went onboard
and found everything
in complete order --
the China plates that we see
there, spoons and knives and forks,
likely which if they saw them, they
probably would have taken them,
being quite useful
to modify the tools.
And this rather interesting
artifact,
this is a turned wooden table leg,
it's mahogany with a detach
-- attached stretcher.
And clearly, a table,
of -- but we --
we suspected it might
in fact be this table.
This is an illustration from -- of
the Illustrated London News of 1845,
during the month of departure.
And actually, purports
to show Franklin's own
cabin and this table here.
And actually the -- the sonar
imagery shows that a big bite
of the stern, the great cabin was
bitten away by the ice and a lot
of these materials now have been
deposited straight to the seafloor.
So, it's quite possibly
what we see right there.
So this is the area in the --
in the lower deck where we are
encountering a lot of these plates
and -- and other scientific
instruments
and some other things I'll show you.
But this is the area where the
common sailors would sling --
sling their hammocks
and take their meals.
In fact, if you look up at the
-- the upper deck beams overhead,
you can see the hammock tags with
the numbers on them showing you
where your particular
allotted space is.
This is incredible detail.
Again on the lower
deck inside the ship,
this is a large chest
apparently some
of the contents preserved inside.
This we believe would have doubled
as the seats that they used for --
at the mess tables as
the ship's plans show.
This very delicate thing here
is -- you can see it here.
This is a sword hilt or the
handle of a -- of a naval cutlass,
which still preserves the --
all these subtle details, the --
the sharkskin grip, the lion head
-- the [inaudible] and the --
even the gold wire braid that kind
of holds the -- the grip together.
Very, very ornate and really
interesting to us archaeologically,
but quite possibly of no
interest whatsoever to the Inuit
who quite possibly snapped off the
-- the steel blade and discarded,
you know, this piece of, you know,
useless junk, as they would see it.
So as we go ahead with
the archeological study
of the wreck of the Erebus.
We now go through -- we now enter
in to a very interesting stage
where this is showing how
we've divided the area
into [inaudible] areas
in order to contextualize
where artifacts come from, to help
us identify associations with --
with other finds to learn
more about the ship.
And it's where we'll be in --
in a position to answer some
of these more interesting
archaeological questions.
We believe that the ship was likely
re-manned, as the Inuit's suggest.
We hope to go and identify
and show how it sank.
We note that there's a [inaudible]
nearby with some materials lost
or -- or deposited nearby
which possibly means
that they may have escaped
the clutches of the ice only
to run aground and
have the ship sink.
Perhaps they didn't have enough
manpower at this point to --
to adequate man the ship's pumps
and/or to lighten to get it off.
Hopefully we'll find out.
In the case of --
of the Investigator where
you can start seeing the --
the tensions simmering as
men who are on short rations
and the officers are starting
to second guess, perhaps the --
the command decisions
or at least privately.
Did the discipline of the
Franklin Expedition breakdown?
If the men came back to the
ship, was it because the --
the party had fractured or was
it all survivors at that point
who returned to the ship?
We don't know.
Is -- anthropologically, is there
evidence of the Inuit going onboard
and harvesting useful raw
materials, sifting through materials
on the lower deck, collecting the
knives and discarding the ship's,
you know, portraits and
paintings and that sort of thing?
We have to be able to test some
of the prevailing hypothesis
about what happened to
the Franklin Expedition,
Inuit reports seeing
unopened tins of -- of meat.
Maybe we'll find them, maybe
we'll be able to test the quality.
The theory of lead poisoning being
a longstanding contributing factor,
as -- as has been hypothesized.
So we'll beable to test
some of these views.
And ultimately, archaeologically
we want to figure out what happened
in the final stages of
the Franklin Expedition
and what really caused
the expedition to fail.
Although I -- I think that's
really [inaudible] question
because I think the Franklin
Expedition failed on May 1845,
when they received their
orders from the Admiralty.
And really that's when
they were directed into one
of the worst ice choke points
in the Canadian Arctic.
A place situated along the west
coast of King William Island
where the Inuit would
almost never travel
because there's nothing
to subsist on.
What we can tell from the --
the [inaudible] note left on
King William Island recovered
by the McClintock party, as
Franklin apparently ordered his --
followed his orders to the letter.
He was proceeding after trying
to identify a north Polar Sea,
which doesn't exist, but proceeding
southwest to the surveyed part
of the North American mainland.
I'm not sure that -- that Franklin
and his men really
ever stood a chance,
no matter what they would have
done, which as most brings us
to this interesting question of the
discovery of the North-West Passage,
which -- which Glenn
was speaking to.
And I can't help but think of the --
the Franklin Monument that is placed
in Waterloo Place in London, where
really at the assistance of his wife
or widow, Lady Jane Franklin,
the credit was given to Franklin
and his men for forging
the last link
of the North-West Passage
with their lives.
This years after the Investigator
and the crew had been awarded
the 10,000 pound Admiralty prize
for accomplishing that feat.
Of course, they live
to tell the tale
and that really is the
fundamental difference.
Significantly whoever --
finding Erebus where it lies,
and given the possibility
that we might be able
to test archaeologically
that it had been re-manned.
There's every possibility that the
men onboard that ship new exactly
where they were and in fact,
knew that they had affected
that last link and had
linked up with the --
the shoreline survey by
Simpson [inaudible] in 1839.
It was probably a small
consolation for the fate
that would surely befall on whoever.
I'll leave it at that and in hopes
that we might have some
interesting questions and discussion
with whatever time remains.
And I thank you very
much for your interest.
Cheers.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Harbster: If you can
-- if you can repeat the questions.
>> Ryan Harris: Yes.
>> Jennifer Harbster: Do we
have any questions for Ryan?
Sir?
>> I'm surprised Canada [inaudible]
analysis of the Erebus site
or search for the Terror
[inaudible] before?
>> Ryan Harris: Yes.
The question is whether we're
going to concentrate our efforts
on steadying the wreck site of
H.M.S. Erebus or also continue
in searching for the
second ship, the Terror.
And yes, last summer we
did both concurrently,
which is quite a challenge.
And we have instructions
to continue to --
to try to locate the
second wreck as well.
And ultimately we look at it
as together these ships are a
designated national historic site
in Canada.
And really together, we need to have
both to flush out all the details
of what happened to the
-- to the Franklin party.
Also, first to protect and preserve
that second wreck site for --
for posterity, for the benefit of --
of Canadians and people who
are interested worldwide.
We have to identify the
wreck site and figure
out what sort of condition it's in.
So yes, we will be continuing that
effort for the foreseeable future.
>> Two things on the demise
that came to my detection.
Could Franklin had backed
out when he hit that ice
that you and I were discussing?
I had an impression that he had a
shot at getting out [inaudible].
And the second thing, the food
poisoning, hadn't it already set
into the extent that without
some alternate source of food,
they were going to die anyway?
>> Ryan Harris: Yes,
very good questions.
I wish I could say demise with
that sort of a dramatic emphasis
that you were capable
of, and that's great.
You has asked when -- when the
ships became beset in Larson Sound,
so north of King William Island
in 1846, was that avoidable?
Ultimately, was -- was
that an error in judgment?
Well, we don't necessarily know,
I mean, that's sort of difficult
to reconstruct those moments,
but what we certainly can say
having surveyed in those waters
for several years now, that the
ice conditions can change very,
very quickly.
Particularly late in the
season, come late September,
there's an almost inexhaustible
supply of ice constantly coming
down McClintock Channel
to the northwest.
And that if the wind -- the wind had
been blowing easterly and then all
of a sudden swung to the northwest,
very quickly there would be a wall
of ice right on top of them.
You can also experience
flash freezes where a change
in wind direction will bring
remarkably colder temperatures
and you can have dramatic
freezing right away.
A lot of this information
comes to us
from a historical ice climatology
study that was conducted for us
by Tom Zagonoff -- Zagon of
our Canadian Ice Service,
trying to reconstruct the prevailing
patterns of ice formation drift
and breakup in Victoria Strait to
help us try to narrow our search,
because otherwise we're left
with a considerable area.
Also a -- yeah, it's -- it's --
it's [inaudible] safe if they
would have had anywhere else to go,
they couldn't necessarily
have just doubled back
and gone up Peel Sound again.
>> [Inaudible] you
say they could not --
>> Ryan Harris: We don't know, but
it's almost amazing that they got
down Peel Sound in the first place.
In the same way that unusual ice
conditions allowed Investigator
to enter Mercy Bay in late
September, which we never see today.
Somehow Peel Sound happened to be
navigable for Franklin and his men
when it hadn't been for
any other expedition prior.
So really, the ice it sort
of set the -- the trap.
I think you might have used this
reference in your book, but yeah,
they kind of blundered
into it in both cases
and then couldn't get
out, it's like a snare.
Also they didn't know at that
time, unless they explored it,
that there was water to the
east of King William Island,
what is now James Clark Ross Strait.
This was still perceived
to be a peninsula attaching
to -- to Boothia.
So yeah, it's a difficult
question, but it's tough -- it's --
I don't think we can second
guess what happened to them, I --
I'm sure they were making every
effort to avoid being beset
in the ice if they
could possibly help it,
but I doubt it was avoidable.
And the second part of your
question, sorry I -- I --
>> Food poisoning --
>> Ryan Harris: -- food poisoning.
Which of course, relates to the work
of forensic anthropologist Owen
Beattie from the University
of Alberta, who disinterred the
three graves on Beechey Island,
was able to collect tissue
samples from -- from hair and --
and what have you, and was able
to identify a significantly
elevated concentration
of lead in those tissues.
And that led him to hypothesize
that lead poisoning not necessarily
would've been the fatal outdoing
of the expedition, but it may have
been a significant mitigating factor
that would've clouded their
judgement and made these --
well would've made it even more
miserable than it already was.
The theory of lead poisoning has
been subjected to a lot of scrutiny
in recent years and it might be a
prevailing view that we really need
to revisit that -- that hypothesis.
I think the research needs to be
done to identify whether their level
of lead poisoning was in
any way unusual for people
from Victorian England,
where lead was ubiquitous.
Used in pencils and
paint, and tobacco tins,
and lead crystal, lead pipes.
It was used everywhere and they
didn't know the pernicious effects
at the time.
So were these lead
levels any different
from anyone else at the time?
It's tough to say.
But if it was a problem, then it
would've been exasperated over time.
It would have theoretically
have worsened.
But no doubt there are other things
that would have been at play.
Scurvy being the typical ailment
that befalls most artic expeditions
that happen to linger
past three years.
And three years really seems to
be this kind of pivotal moment
where in Mercy Bay, in 1853,
under shortened rations,
where your body is weaker and
weaker, you hear a concept called
"Artic Scurvy," I think that
Andrew Lambert talks about.
Where you're even more subject to
the debilitating effects of scurvy
when you're on shortened
rations and your body is cold,
and you just never get a
chance to recover fully.
So yeah, I think there's a lot
of research to do to figure
out really what happened.
In the back?
>> I'm curious about your minimum
sources and what form those take,
and what sort of records
[inaudible]?
>> Ryan Harris: Yeah, with
a bit more time to drone on,
I would've gone into
some of those details.
Really, the search parties in the
mid-19th century, so John Rae,
McClintock, Hall, Schlaka [phonetic]
they all interviewed Inuit
informants, often with the
question, "Do you know anything
about these kabloonak,
these white men
that appeared however
many years ago?"
Do you know where they went?
Do you know where these ships are?
And in some cases those
accounts are amazingly detailed.
I mentioned Mr. Petorak [phonetic],
who gives clear indications
that as they saw, the ship had
been remand in the Queen Mont Gulf.
That there were fresh sweepings
from under a ship's doors
that were still being maintained.
Ultimately, they found
a corpse on board.
That a heavyset individual
they had difficulty removing,
so they just left him
on the cabin floor.
An individual we may have come
across archeologically and be able
to figure out who it was
through DNA sampling,
and surely that possibility.
And -- but a fairly substantial
of corpus of Inuit observations
that have been picked
over through the years.
Certainly David Woodman, the author
from Victoria, British Columbia,
has probably done the most to try
to weave all of this information
into a coherent narrative.
As he will point out, the challenge
for historians and archeologists
in trying to Inuit testimony
is that it has been filtered
through several different
lenses by that time,
and then well we have
recorded references
to a shipwreck being gasunken
[phonetic] in Schlaka's [phonetic]
and his party's account eight
miles west of Grant Point.
The Inuit would not have been west.
They wouldn't have said Grant Point.
They wouldn't have said east
either -- or west rather.
That a completely different
world view
that makes these observations
difficult to decipher.
When they talk about days'
travel -- well a day of travel --
in terms of gauging distance --
is a very different thing for
a well Navy sled party as it
with a lightly laden and experienced
group of Inuit who habituated
to Arctic travel for
their entire lives.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Yeah, I was going to say one
more, because I know we have
to do the book signing and we
have a lunch reservation at 1:30.
>> Really quickly, down at the
national archives we're working
on digitization project where we
are digitizing all the US Navy,
Coast Guard vessel log books,
[inaudible] and posting them online.
And [inaudible], I was hoping you
could comment on how these types
of projects -- although many
are going on here at the library
as well -- how those
projects impact you
as an underwater archeologist
and [inaudible]?
>> Ryan Harris: Yes, I could
certainly say that I wish
that the Smithsonian had
digitized the manuscripts
of the Charles Frances Hall, because
they would've saved us the effort
of coming down and
copy them in facsimile.
Yes, these are incredible
repositories.
Research afoot to really
pour into the log books
of all these expeditions to try
to recreate climatological
patterns of the mid-19th century.
It's really an untapped resource
and definitely those sort
of journals will contribute to that.
>> I'm sorry, repeat again what
you're specifically asking?
>> As an historian, how --
>> I knew you had fallen asleep.
>> Well what more resources
are available online
for these [inaudible] projects
here at the library and elsewhere,
I'm just wondering how's
that -- how as a historian,
how is that changing the way
you do internet research or?
>> Glenn Stein: It changes it
slightly in that I use the,
throughout the time I was writing
the book, I used the internet
as a pointer for where artifacts,
and certainly repository
for art projects stored.
But the problem is this, is that
you wouldn't get the whole picture
unless you were onsite.
And unfortunately you can't
always trust some of the things
that are actually said in the
records as to what the objects are.
For instance, one journal
that was described
in the archives was
not a journal at all.
It was a book manuscript, a
draft of a manuscript written
in the form of a journal.
So it was totally misleading
until I got onsite and I looked
at the actual item and I said,
"Well, this is not a journal.
This is written like a journal,"
which means, okay, it's been edited.
So it's very helpful to have these
things onsite or online for me,
but there's nothing like being
there -- let's put it that way.
There's nothing like being there.
You really have to take it all in.
And you will not believe
how much I found
where I did not expect
to find anything.
Because again, there were
errors in cataloguing.
Things were not catalogued
necessarily as well.
And I found other correspondence
in certain folders,
which sometimes was very helpful
and other times had nothing whatever
to do with what I was looking at.
So I think you have to be
very careful about that.
I think you have to really be there.
I went twice to England
and spent a lot
of time looking at
everything I could.
Having my hands on it.
And by the way -- just to
finish off, there's nothing
like comparing handwriting.
Because I found-- and this
is what I did with my book --
I found it very important to
put that an item was a copy
of a letter, or a copy of something.
And you would notice that the
handwriting was not the same.
So, yes, it was a copy not
in that same person's hand.
It becomes very subtle -- a lot
of subtleties involved here --
which I hope translated
well into my writing.
Oh, by the way, I want to mention
that I misspoke when I was talking
about McClure's anti-steam
[inaudible] mentor,
it was James Clark Ross, not his
uncle, John Ross, who was anti-steam
and impressed that
so much on McClure.
>> All right.
Thank you.
So [inaudible]?
>> Yeah, I just -- can I
sneak in one more question.
What's left to be done
with the investigation?
[Inaudible], what has
to be done still?
>> Ryan Harris: Yeah, I mean, of the
200 hours that we have on the wreck
of the Erebus, we have much
time on record investigator.
So in fact if we had our druthers,
we probably would've been happy
with diving on the investigator
to this date, but we're encouraged
to continue the search for
Erebus and [inaudible].
It became certainly a source of
great interest for our cabinet.
So we're eager to go back
to the investigator site,
but really we're just
scratching the surface.
In many ways, what we
might stand to learn
from the Erebus wreck
archeologically might be more
influential in reconstructing
than the history of what happened.
As the fate of the investigators
is pretty well documented.
It is -- I am sure what
Glenn would hope for is
that at some point we'll come across
some preserved paper, materials --
which is not impossible at all.
With all that silt and the
cold water temperatures,
and the darkness, being covered by
ice for, you know, 85% of the year
or longer, there's
definitely the prospect
of those sort of materials
surviving.
Is there a journal cached in
one of the cabins somewhere
that never made it off the ship?
You never know.
>>Thank you.
[ Applause ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.